you know her as Elizabeth Shaw the
intrepid scientist who makes a brief
appearance in Ridley Scott's alien
covenant after starring in its
predecessor Prometheus but the woman who
plays her Swedish actress Noomi Rapace
has been heating up Hollywood sister
breakout in 2009 here are all the places
you've seen her before the Millennium
Trilogy thanks to director David Fincher
and a 90 million dollar Hollywood budget
you've probably heard of The Girl with
the Dragon Tattoo and its titular
protagonist the brooding tattooed
Lisbeth Salander but two years before
Rooney Mara earned an Oscar nomination
for playing Stieg Larsson heroine knew
Mira Paz played the role to great
acclaim in her native Sweden in fact
it's unlikely that Lisbeth Salander
would have ever gotten a big-budget
outing in mainstream Hollywood
if the Swedish actress hadn't turned in
such a stunner of a performance first
while the girl with the dragon tattoo is
pretty much a household name Sieg
Larson's millennium book series was
actually adapted as a trilogy Noomi
Rapace reprised her role as Lisbeth
Salander in few more movies the girl who
played with fire and The Girl Who Kicked
the hornets nest
also ripoff spent a fool here playing
Lisbeth a performance that resulted in
three feature films six television
episodes worth of raw material and rave
reviews across the board however once
she was done she was really done in an
interview with NPR the actress said
quote it was kind of strange you know
the last day after we filmed the last
scene all the producers came with
champagne and everybody wanted to
celebrate and I just said I need to go
to the bathroom and I just started to
throw up it was like my body was
physically throwing Lisbeth out and
quote the monitor compared to repository
with the Dragon Tattoo the Swedish
horror film the monitor was pretty low
profile accepted Whedon but fans of the
genre will recognize it and more
importantly its leading lady for her
pitch perfect performance as a woman on
the brink of insanity the monitor is an
understated slow burner featuring the
creepiest home appliance ever the baby
monitor replies as a traumatised single
mother who just wants to listen to her
kid while he sleeps
but gets an earful of something sinister
and said Sherlock Holmes a game of
shadows for those who hadn't already
discovered Humira paws via the Dragons
had to trilogy there was no missing her
in her big-budget debut alongside Robert
Downey jr. and Jude Law ripoff Slade
madam Simza in Sherlock Holmes a game of
shadows channeling her trademark
ferocity into the role of a Romani gypsy
woman who gets caught up in a deadly
conspiracy spearheaded by Sherlock arch
nemesis Moriarty and her performance is
doubly impressive because she had to
cross a huge language barrier to do it
replies revealed in an interview close I
didn't speak English like three years
ago and for me to find a way to be free
and be able to live in this language
instead of feeling like you're stuck in
this prison of control where you can do
perfect lines but you can't improvise
and you can't ad-lib after a week I've
forgotten about it it's the way they
work those boys are fantastic and slow
dead man down of course you recognize
new Meera paws from Prometheus but after
leaving the Alien franchise new Meera
paws reunited with Niels Arden Oplev the
man who held the original Swedish the
girl with a dragon tattoo for dead man
down in addition to replies said man
down also boasts a cast that includes
Colin Farrell Dominic Cooper and
Terrence Howard unfortunately despite
all that star power the movie itself
wasn't particularly well received by
anyone one critic at variety called it
revenge fantasy dress and a derivative
collection of brazen plot holes and
late-night cable cliches the drop
adapted by Dennis Lehane from his own
short story animal rescue the drop is a
quiet film noir about crime vengeance
and decent men who do very bad things in
the basements of Brooklyn bars and for
new Meera paws it presented a serious
challenge namely having to hold her own
on screen against not just Tom Hardy
who've just become super famous after
doing inception and the Dark Knight
Rises back to back but also the world's
most adorable pitbull puppies child 44
perhaps thanks to her incredible
chemistry with Tom Hardy and the drop
new mera posture nup immediately in
another movie with the British actor
time as his life in the Soviet era
thriller child 44 in it hearty plays
disgrace solemn security officer Rio
Gemma dog who tries to track a serial
killer against the wishes of his
government though this film didn't get
as much attention as some of her pastas
other projects thanks to a limited
release in the u.s. everyone turned in
solid performances that made for a tense
effective political thriller even if
everyone in it struggles occasionally
with their Russian accent thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to